[Music]
you're very good at accents from around
the globe I've heard that you I've heard
you've claimed that you can do an accent
from any region any suburb of any region
any town in the world that you've
mastered it to that extent yes I can do
any accent accurately you can check up
on it I any any small part of a town any
big city whatever you want I can do it
all united states around the world any
of them okay now I'm gonna tell them I
have this I assure you we have not
talked about this at all you don't know
what's coming I've made it I have a list
here okay I'm just gonna try them out on
you and let's see he can really do I
really don't know this idea he really
does not know these okay here we go
Minsk of in Russia Minsk Minsk is very
tightly tied to Russia it they know
struggle with the English so Minsk da da
spasiba
so like masks Abimelech spasiba more
open for Russia for Moscow but Minsk
Minsk it's a tighter tighter it says it
I gotta have to believe you it sounds
good okay Hamburg Germany Hamburg
Anatole so in Germany so here so well
Munich is Munich as a little mission
like this but Hamburg yes and it's a
little important so that's important
it's there the most educated and so so
so Berlin is a little more like loud and
the confident but Hamburg is more
conservative
Fargo North Dakota Fargo Fargo it's not
like you think it is it's not because
it's not like it's not like the show and
it's not like the movies you've seen but
there is something kind of it's a little
faster than you think it's a little
faster and you kick hard by she kind of
I always think of fire got for you open
up the A's open them up firing oh yeah
North Dakota caught up not not to quota
it's de cada Takata Jamaica
[Applause]
help
it's gonna come off so terrible jerk
chicken jerk take a break more with this
fraud Fred Armisen
[Applause]
you